it's one thing to attack your political
opponents on Twitter the Democrat Party
has gone completely insane it's another
to do it while your political base is
cheering you on
that's how US President Donald Trump
spent his Friday night
first they engineered the Russia hoax
that was a total hoax the single
greatest lies ever moistured upon the
American people then the mower
witch-hunt it never ended and now
corrupt politicians Nancy Pelosi
and shifty Adam Schiff shifty
and the media are continuing with the
deranged impeachment which oh this is
one I never thought I'd be involved in
the word impeachment to me it's a dirty
word the rally was Trump's first since
the House of Representatives formally
endorsed the impeachment inquiry against
him on Thursday Trump told the crowd he
never pressured ukrainian President
Vladimir zalenski to investigate former
Vice President Joe Biden and his son
hunter and that he did not withhold
nearly four hundred million dollars in
military aid to force Solinsky to comply
at the same time several Democratic
candidates campaigned for votes in Iowa
and Joe Biden used the event to fire
back at Trump Vladimir Putin doesn't
want me to be President and number two
Donald Trump doesn't want me to be the
nominee
spend a lot of money to make sure I'm
not I'm flattered a Capitol Hill next
week Democrats once again will question
Trump administration officials behind
closed doors while some officials have
already appeared others are refusing to
show up the latest energy secretary Rick
Perry who says there was nothing wrong
with Trump's call to szalinski yeah I
wanted the president make the phone call
because I thought it was important if
you base which I do everything to do
with this back to the point that the
United States has the ability to give
Ukraine a alternative to Russian gas
legislators could issue a subpoena
forcing Perry to appear or risk being
arrested and we will make America great
again thank you Mississippi thank you
raising the ante and the pressure on a
president who says he will fight what he
calls an illegal effort to undermine his
ruled rosiland Jordan al Jazeera
Washington